[Music]
my name is Fred and I'm a data addict
feel free to ask questions throughout
the presentation so I'm a developer
evangelist at Sur CONUS which means I'm
an engineer who goes around and talks to
people I've been in recovering scene
programmer for a while though I've
started to write C code again and I
really love it I've been using
histograms for operational series
monitoring operational time series
monitoring for about seven years but
I've really been geeking out on
histograms for the past couple years
sorts of CONUS we do large-scale very
high volume time series operational
telemetry and the development of our
systems has been driven through pain
when Sir CONUS started about eight years
ago the people doing it the founders set
out to solve problems with distributed
systems and so they used observability
tools like dtrace and what they got was
just a firehose of telemetry from that
so they tried hooking up you know
monitoring systems like Nagios i'm not
sure if zavok was around that time to it
and basically those systems just fell
over and a lot of those systems also
were using averages as metrics and as
they found that and you know that gives
you one one data point but for doing
statistical analysis and advanced
computations it's really kind of useless
so they set out to start to use
histograms to solve this problem
so who here is familiar with histograms
raise your hand if you use bees one Wow
I was pretty good about 75% so I'll just
go through some of the basics this is a
histogram
it's a skewed histogram because the you
know the mode is on the far left you can
see you know the median is around the
middle it's to the left of the mean
because the histogram values are skewed
to the left the 90th percentile also
known as the 0.9 quantile is up there to
the right 90% of the values are below
that and the maximum value in quantile
notation is q1 at the far right the cue
notation for quantile notation notation
is just a fancy way of representing
percentiles so this is a heat map and
this is basically a series of histograms
over time each vertical slice is one
histogram of data this altogether is
about I think about six million data
points and the red portion of the heat
map represents a large sample density so
this is actually load balancer request
latency and as you can see you know
you've got grouping there in the middle
where it's red on the scales at the
bottom and so you can see a lot of the
requests kind of group around the 500
nanosecond threshold and originally when
I saw this I was like wow this looks
like you know the display from Knight
Rider in about TV service movies with
David Hasselhoff but no this actually
contains a wealth of useful information
so I'm going to go over a few histogram
types there's fixed bucket approximate
histograms linear log linear human live
and then we've got a bonus 1/2 so fixed
bucket histograms are histograms where
you specify the bin boundaries manually
the terms bucket and bin are kind of
interchangeable buckets more of an
industry term but if you look at some of
the academic literature they use the
terminology bin
so this has some some traits as it you
know if you're if you're using something
like this to collect data odds are
you're not going to get an optimal
you're not going to find the optimal bin
boundaries there are some mathematical
theorems you can use to do that like
Sturges theorem that's a bit out of the
scope of this talk it's a little bit
difficult to merge different histograms
together that have fixed buckets because
often you're not going to get a
standardized bin boundary I keep saying
bucket when I should be saying bin but
these are commonly used in time series
telemetry the Prometheus monitoring
system uses these approximate histograms
so this is an example of an approximate
histogram is was one was developed by
Ted Dunning and it was called the tea
digest and basically the way it works is
you have a set of centroids here and
each centroid on each centroid the
distribution of samples surrounding that
centroid or equal so you've got an equal
number of samples represented on either
side of the centroids and so these kind
of represent groupings of data that
would correspond to the bars on the
histogram these tend to be very memory
efficient structures and have high
accuracy at extreme percentiles
but at median percentiles they do have
some you know non-trivial errors around
10% with small sample sizes do we have a
question okay
in terms of other traits they are very
marginal easy to merge with other
histograms linear histograms pardon me
linear histograms so these are
histograms that have evenly spaced bins
so you could have like you know if you
have a range of values you know point 1
to 10,000 you could have bins every
point 1 now going up to 10,000 obviously
that's a tremendous number of bin sizes
so you know you do suffer from some
exceptions excessive memory usage if you
implement this in a production system
you do get some you know low accuracy at
the your lower values but there's also a
trade-off there like as you go with
higher values you get higher accuracy
because the bins become a fraction of
your data set size but generally this is
you know not really this histogram type
doesn't have a lot of pluses so
log-linear histograms this one's my
bread and butter this is what sir conics
uses so these are histograms with
logarithmically increasing bin sizes so
you'll have 0.1 to 1 1 to 10 10 200 100
mm and so these allow you to capture a
wide range of data points without really
having to know up front like you know
what what is my data set look like do I
have data from a million to 10 million
do I have data from you know 0.125 these
kind of fit all data sets very well you
can have worst-case errors of I think
five percents if you know you have one
sample that's on the very edge of a
bucket say lucky if you have a sample of
one oh nine point nine that gets grouped
into the 100 to 110 bucket and gets
represented as 105 but we don't really
use histograms to store single values we
want to store thousands tens of
thousands or millions of values in these
histograms to examine the data HD our
histograms high dynamic range histograms
are another type of log-linear histogram
that you'll see in industry and we're
going to dive into this in depth and a
little bit cumulative histograms these
ones are pretty interesting so the way
that a cumulative histogram works is
each successive bin moving right
contains the number of samples of the
bins on the left so they kind of stack
together and the bin on the far right is
going to contain the total sample count
of all the samples in the histogram you
may have seen this if you've ever looked
at photography
color gradients you'll see kind of like
a black and white threshold curve that's
a cumulative histogram is sometimes
known as a cumulative distribution
function this does have some significant
advantages in that you know it's very
easy or it's easier to calculate
quantiles you know if I want my q1 my
hundred-percent maximum that's just the
count on the end if I've got an even
number of buckets and I want to know my
my medium value I just go to the middle
bucket and look at the count there so
this has this has some advantages in
telemetry monitoring systems Google uses
this type of histogram for their monarch
monitoring system so they're using it at
a fairly decent scale and when I was
putting this presentation together
actually when I was researching
histograms I made a mistake and I
thought oh well cumulative histogram I
read the description wrong I'm like well
that that just adds up values you know
over time and I was totally wrong but
what I realized was you know you can
take the traits of any of these
histograms and put them together to
create a custom histogram if you've got
a well known data set or if you just
want to try something new so say if let
me go back to the cumulative histogram
if this indeed does represent increasing
values over time so I could have a very
flat histogram at time equals zero and I
could have something like this at time
equals 100 well then I could you know if
I wanted to calculate my you know 99th
percentile for that whole time range
I've got essentially an o1 operation
you know constant space and time
operation to do that calculation because
I don't have to go through you know t1
t2
all the way to T 99 and some practice of
these histograms so you can kind of you
know if you find you've got a unique
data set data set and something that you
might be able you know that some of
these other histograms don't fit well
you can go ahead and roll your own it's
not that difficult
so I'm gonna start diving into the open
source histogram implementation that
we've done the log-linear implementation
if you got some of your laptop's out I'm
sure folks do you you can follow along
these are you know we have a CD library
and we have a goal-line library so if
you want to pull these up you can take a
look through the code and search for I
think it's a proxy quantile function
because I'm gonna be going through like
you know how do we take a log linear
histogram no implementation and compute
quantiles and later on compute inverse
quantiles and do really fun things with
them and we'll you know be addressing
like you know why does why do this
histogram Stealth scale and why is it
fast so this is a visual representation
of one of our log-linear histograms if
you look at it's about a hundred
thousand through a million in terms of
sample values you'll see the buckets are
very finely divided and then at 1
million the bucket size increases this
next slide shows it a bit better so we
subdivide each power of 10 bin size into
90 bins and originally look you know
when I started looking at this in depth
I was like well why isn't it 100 I'm
like oh well it's you know 10 minus 1 is
9 and so if you divide that evenly
you've got 90 so I was a little
misleading to me at first but at each
logarithmic exponential change we
increase the bin size by 10x and so this
sum you know this gives us a lot of
accuracy while still giving us a very
high dynamic range you know depending on
our sample set this is a different
representation just a different
visualization of the same log-linear
histogram the bucket transition is a
little bit clearer here it occurs looks
like around a thousand where we increase
the bucket size so how do you put
something like this into code
the way that we do it is we this is our
bin data structure in both the C and go
code it's got three components we've got
the value so say if I wanted to
represent you know one point six I would
represent that as an 8-bit integer but I
would multiply it by ten so really my
value is value times ten and then if I
you know say I'm doing one point six my
exponent is going to be zero so one
point six times ten to the zero is one
point six so I've got I've essentially
allocated two bytes here for specifying
a value and an exponent the exponent
does have a range of negative 128 to 127
so we can take you know very you know
very fractional very precise fractional
values represented in this histogram so
and then we have also the count the
counts represented as a unsigned 64-bit
integer so we get a maximum of eight
bytes there so as you know we can store
essentially an unlimited count in there
for all intents and purposes
it is a maximum of eight bytes that it
takes but we have applied a variable bit
encoding so in some cases we can
represent a histogram bin in less than
there represent the count in less than
eight bytes and so we get the cat the
whole structure and less than ten bytes
so that's a fairly memory efficient it's
not 100% optimized but it's it was good
enough that we could really scale our
system pretty far so if you were to just
have a similar data structure like an 8
byte or 64-bit integer to record average
values you can
you know do the same thing that's pretty
efficient but obviously you know you're
only getting one value if you're just
using it bits to store or eight bits to
store sorry eight bytes to store an
integer but with a histogram data
structure like this you can store
essentially an unlimited amount of
samples within a very narrow range so
what what kind of efficiency do we get
with a structure like this worst case
scenario
I'd put out the calculations here so one
question there is like how you know if I
showed you this histogram back here
what's you know how many bins do we have
practically speaking we found that all
of our data sets we've never gotten any
more than 300 bins used to represent the
whole range of data and at 10 bytes have
been you know and all the other
conversion factors you're looking at
about a hundred and twenty four mags to
store 30 days of one-minute histograms
that's quite a bit of operational data I
can store you know latency from you know
a thousand servers aggregated over 30
days in 124 Meg's and that's also you
know sub-second dis read so it's it's
very performant additionally the bins
are not pre-allocated when we store them
so if I have you know a range of 0.1 to
a million I'm not going to allocate
every single bin upfront and then leave
empty bins we only allocate memory as
needed so that allows us to you know
really get an efficient footprint here
now if I were to compare this to say 30
days of 1-minute average data that takes
you know about a third of a megabyte but
you know once again that's you know
you've got 30 days of average data
points that's not very useful you can't
do much with that
similarly for a year the footprint is
not that big we can merge histograms
together I mentioned before like if you
lined up the bin boundaries you can
easily merge histograms together
programmatically so we can take take
that one minute data we had in the
previous previous slide here we can
merge it into five minutes histograms
and we can get five minute data
distribution resolution for a year and
that takes up about three hundred Meg's
so you know again on most monitoring
system that's you know sub second read
and if you'll notice the total total
number of samples you know is somewhat
invariant to the total data set size the
biggest factors are in how much data is
stored are the span of bins that you're
covering you know once again we found
300 to be about the maximum and also the
compression factor for bin you know
we're using variable bit encoding so
that can that can change so I showed
before you know we we can have 90th
percentiles we can have medians we can
have 99 percentiles
how do we calculate those from the
histogram data structures that we've
shown so if if we use the quantile
notation Q of X where X ranges from zero
to one one being the maximum the
calculations are actually not that
difficult what you want to do is
essentially sum up account of every
single bin and if you recall the
cumulative histogram the far right bin
holds the maximum value you've got an O
one operation there now instead of you
know an O n operation for most of the
other histograms so you can get you know
I think that might be why Google's using
it with monarch you can get a little bit
of optimization there and then once you
have once you have that count you know
if I want the the median the 50th
percentile I would multiply 0.5 times
that count to get you know what I'm
calling queue queue is basically that
count in the histogram where I want to
find the corresponding value
so once I once I've got that you know
say we have you know cute or X is 0.5 C
is 1000 you know we're gonna get Q
equals 500 we want to walk the bins some
the the boundary counts of each bin
until we hit the bin where 500 is in the
middle of the left boundary count I'm
sorry the right boundary count and the
left boundary count and from there we
can use linear interpolation to
calculate what my value is for that
quantile now this this this might be a
bit heavy without you know writing this
down but I'll be happy to go in this in
depth at office hours but linear
interpolation so say you know we're
looking for you know Q of I'm sorry
we're taking the 50 percentile and Q
turns out to be 700 we can use this
formula here I don't know how many folks
remember well it was middle school when
I took it algebra I drove into this and
this is directly from the code if you
guys are following along in the code we
basically take the left value of the bin
which is 1.0 add that to you
700 minus the count of samples at the
left bin boundary and we divide that by
the right bin boundary count
- left bin boundary count times the bin
width which is 0.1 and that gives us our
answer of 1.05 so quantile calculations
here are not mysterious they're not as
as difficult as as they may seem and
it's pretty straightforward to implement
and I want to emphasize once again you
know cumulative histogram really does
have an advantage over here because you
don't have to do that initial operation
of walking each bin and getting a sum up
account and so I'm going to do a quick
recap here we looked at you know several
different types of histograms and how
you can do your own showed the data
structure
and how it's space efficient but you
know the title of this talk is you know
managing effective management of high
volume data so you can kind of see that
we have a space efficient structure but
and that gives us some scalability but
how do we make it fast
in terms of programmatic approaches
there are certain things that you should
do and that we do you want to avoid
allocating memory unless necessary if
you look at the seeing limitation that I
showed earlier it does as much it goes
through a lot of work to avoid you know
any spurious memory allocations you know
we do have to allocate memory when we
create a new bin you want to avoid
copying data you want to do pointer
arithmetic anywhere you can you want to
avoid weights and you want to avoid
locks so we do use a fair amount of
assembly code to accomplish that
concurrency kit is the library that
we've used to implement our histogram
libraries to make them fast that's built
with a lot of assembly code in there I'm
not recommending that you go out and
start writing assembly code a lot of
people have already done that for you
but what what other things can we can we
do with you know large volumes of data
once we've got in a new structure like
this so the stuff that sir CONUS is
focused on and where we felt the pain in
trying to develop these techniques has
been operational data so say I'm sure
everyone heard about the specter patch
recently where you could use well the
CPU would preemptively calculate
possible branch paths for code and that
turned out to be a security hole because
you could figure out what might happen
before would happen and a patch came out
for that that basically eliminated the
CPUs from doing that well what kind of
effect would that have on say latency of
system calls in your
system well that's something we can we
can use this approach to determine EBP F
extended back Berkey Berkley packet
filter is something that can give us
this call agencies so we can take all of
those put them into a histogram look at
the 99th percentile of that and then we
can apply the Spectre patch we can do
the same thing and we can say hey our
99th percentile time for system calls
has gone from 10 nanoseconds to 30 so
that's a that's a pretty big change in
performance of your system and while
that's well that's a good initial
approach for you know establishing like
a service level objective like what can
I expect my service to return most
requests in what if we could what if we
could flip that around and say like hey
I know that you know 3 seconds is too
long for someone to wait for my service
and I want to know like what percentage
of my requests are violating that 30 or
violating that 3 second service level
objective well we can we can use inverse
quantiles to do that and so an inverse
quantal is essentially looking at
establishing a value that we want our
service to perform at and then deriving
a percentage of requests that have met
that criteria and this is like I
mentioned this is something that humans
are much better at reasoning about you
know say if I have a service that you
know I've got a 10 millisecond service
level objective what percent of my
requests are exceeding that well for
this data set 5% and that's I can
calculate that for 1 histogram but like
I showed in the heatmap previously what
if I want to do that for you know a
month what if I want to look at how my
system changed in dynamically so you
know kind of the reverse of how we
calculated quantiles we can flip that
around reverse the calculations and get
the inverse quantile so instead of
starting with Q
there I'm sorry and so we'll start with
start with our sample value X say we'll
call X 500 milliseconds will lock the
histogram until we find that bin and
then we'll use linear interpolation but
we'll reverse it from our previous
approach and we'll solve for our count
instead of solving for our value and I
hope you guys like algebra this may look
a little bit daunting but it's pretty
simple I'll walk through it quickly so
my sample value is X on the left hand
side and I've got my calculation on the
right hand side this is the same
equation I used to calculate to
calculate the percentile value so I
subtract left value from X then I divide
by the bin width then I multiply that
times the right count - the left count
and I add the left count to the other
side and I'm able to isolate Q I know
this might be a little heavy for a slide
but it just shows you you know algebra
is a good thing to know
so here I've got basically another
example of linear interpolation but
instead of having an equation where I
try to solve for X I try to solve for Q
which is the count here and plugging in
the same values from before I was able
to say okay if if my service level
objective is 1.05 seconds then my value
of Q is 700 so and if I have a total
account here of a thousand samples I
know that I've exceeded my service level
objective by 30 percent so this kind of
flips around the quantile calculations
and does the inverse and I just added
this notation this there's not a lot of
official notation out there in
literature that I could found but this
essentially gives you the means of
calculating how many samples exceeded in
my service level objective so you know
there's a lot of numbers there in a lot
of math but let's take a look at you
know
what what does this look like in
practice what kind of visualizations
does it give you so this is the this is
a heat map as I showed previously the
it's not resolving too well but if you
look at the vertical line that's
basically representation representing a
the histogram overlay at the upper right
so it's a set of histograms over time
now I can add a set of 99th percentile
quantiles turn that up a little bit but
basically if you see these these green
lines that fluctuate up and down you can
see that your 99th percentile is you
know varying pretty wildly over this and
this is a year's worth of data it's
about 600 million samples but as you can
see you've kind of got I think he might
be cutting the lights down a little bit
okay even one second
thank you yeah that's a little bit
better but you can see you know are not
in a percentile for the most part hovers
around 500 milliseconds but you see
these big spikes here every month and it
tops out around 10 seconds ten thousand
milliseconds and I thought why is that
happening I'm like what what happens in
network systems around ten seconds I
thought well there's probably a client
timeout going you know happening in
there somewhere and and this was good
but I send it myself okay you know so I
know my my Nana's percentile is changing
but how you know what if I said like I
want to know you know what percentage of
my samples are exceeding say 500
milliseconds because that's when users
start to get angry so I applied an
inverse quantile to this and now we've
got a yellow line at the top on the
right side right y-axis we have a scale
from zero to 100 so the yellow line
basically follows the percent of
requests that are meeting our service
level objective so we can see you know
before I saw like hey my 99th percentile
went above 10 seconds
well how many representatives actually
violated that well here I can see that
when that happens
I've got about 25 percent of my requests
that are exceeding my service level
objective so I thought well that's
that's pretty useful I know the damage
is you know it's it's giving me about
you know 25 percent of damage in terms
of SLO but like what's what's the
absolute damage you know because this
might be you know in terms of the the
total number requests a percentage is
invariant I might have one request
that's not meaning my service level
objective or I might have a thousand so
I went one step further and I inverted
this and I took that percentage of
requests that weren't meeting the
service level of objective and I
multiplied that times the total number
requests so now these green spikes here
show the total and a number of requests
that are making users angry and this is
this is an important business
because if I've got if this is a
shopping cart service request during a
checkout process I'm losing a lot of
money every time this green line goes up
and I was able to to do all that pretty
easily just from I mean there's about
this is about a week so about 1 million
no this is about 6 million data points
so I'm able to to figure out exactly you
know how many users I'm making angry and
if I can put a dollar value on that I
can figure out how much money I'm losing
you know so I can go to you know go to
the ops guy and say like hey you know
when I told you we need all these
servers this is how much money we're
losing so let's go ahead and put a
portion that money to this but you know
this is this is still kind of this is
just forensic evidence this doesn't help
me when stuff is on fire so what I can
do also is I can calculate well give me
the cumulative me a graph of the
cumulative number of times that I
violated my SLO and we can see that each
time the slope of the graph increases
we've got you know another spike so
that's when stuff is essentially on fire
and I'm losing money I thought well this
is good too but I want to be able to
take action on that and so I took that
count of request that was exceeding the
SLO and I applied an anomaly detection
algorithm to it so this gives me kind of
an anomaly score from 0 to 100 you know
it's not machine learning it's simple
statistics pace there's several of them
out there in the public domain so what I
can do here is create a threshold alert
you know any time you know I see an
anomaly score of over 60 and page my ops
team so this kind of you know this takes
I was able to take kind of the whole
circle of you know I've got a whole
bunch of data you know and I can I can
calculate some meaningful statistics
from it but if I you know push keep
pushing that I can take this all the way
to you know making these actionable
because if you look at most telemetry
systems that are operating on extremely
high volumes of data they'll say like
hey our average was you know average
response time was 5 seconds but what
they don't see is that you know you know
that looks fine but really they're
losing these these important chunks of
data that average is not giving you this
tells you when your systems on fire
tells you when you're losing money so I
was able to you know kind of take take
the whole journey through hey what's a
histogram how do we store it how do we
make it fast how do we store a ton of
them and how can we improve our business
with this
you